do I think they're going to be
successful no i don't i think in this
economy and the survival of print
journalism holding on you know only the
strongest will survive and i'm afraid
that these peripheral publications just
don't have the support of the
advertising community they don't have
the circulation to be able to withstand
the kind of pressures that are going now
on in print journalism do i think they
add something yes i do i think that
there they add a non-mainstream point of
view I think they're their freedom to be
as aggressive and shocking that some of
the more mainstream fashion publications
cannot do given their size given their
readership that just aren't permitted to
have that kind of aggressive artistic
point of view yeah I think it's great
you know in a real world would be
marvelous if everyone could exist and
hold on and we could have choice and
point of view of from all areas in
journalism particularly in its
conversation about fashion but I don't
feel that they are going to be able to
to really survive but you know Conde
Nast the great the Great Conde Nast
publishing Empire has indeed launched
love in the United Kingdom and that is
again Katy grin is the intern chief and
that comes from that world of niche
slightly alternative fashion publication
with the point of view so beginning to
see even with large support of Conde
Nast behind it how that will survive but
I you know I have my fingers crossed but
I have my doubts as well
great question yeah i think you know
under the marvelous leadership of Adam
Moss the editor-in-chief we have tried
to position our fashion with a different
angle we're not trying to be vogue we're
not trying to be a kind of second best
of one of the big fashion titles i think
we approached our full issue in a
vernacular that's actually comes from
our spin-off publication that's on
temporarily on hold called look where we
took the ideas of the collections we
extrapolated those curated them blew
them up and i think in a very graphic
fun exciting way added that to some
really strong written features about the
fashion industry and then combined that
ultimately with an extraordinary
photography portfolio by some of the
world's leading photographers of some of
the world's you know best best
photography agencies and created I think
a very compelling triad between the
features the trends section and an
extraordinary photography portfolio I
think a great combination of originality
and point of view of the season and
really singing to our own drum and I
think it's really puts us apart we stand
apart in a way that I'd like to think we
do on a regular basis and it's also that
great freedom that we can do it our way
and I think in these times we're trying
to be smart and appeal to the reader
appeal to the advertising community if
peel to the designers and everybody out
there and the consumer in a way that
makes you take note and I hope we've
succeeded I think we have
one of the great advantages we have is
we do a spring and a fall issue for the
moment and we do lots of online and you
know if it's all about thigh high boots
and big shoulders we can say that with
great conviction and we can say it loud
and we can say it proud and we can you
know I can talk about the trends of the
season in a very powerful immediate way
when you're a monthly publication and
you've got three to four months where
you've got to talk about a season by
virtue of that you've got to hold on to
your information you can't give it all
up in the august issue you've got to
slowly seep into what the season is
about give everyone a taste in the you
know even some stories start in june
july and then of course august and then
hold your best stories for September and
continue on in October because that
issue comes out actually in the middle
of September just when you're starting
to think about fall so those big BMS
those big monthly it's like Vogue and L
and Harper's Bazaar can't say you know
hear the ten things you need to know
here the 15 items this is what we love
this is what we love from the show's
here's the color you got to have they
have to be a much cager quieter subtler
point of view and they do it through
stories longer stories where we now say
it in a much more brutal out there
slightly more in-your-face manner which
i think is fun and contemporary and of
the times and again sets us apart is not
being a sort of sloppy second version of
those guys all of that saying you know
vogue does have the power to do those
beautiful stories if anyone's seen the
sep tember issue that grace coddington
and her teammates to and all the power
to them that's their world that's their
vernacular that's what they can do
they've got the resources and the
history to do that and I hope they
continue to do that we just do something
else which i think is interesting
equally as compelling but sets us apart
yeah I think it will be relevant for
Vogue and some of the other ones that
survived I do think there's going to be
some attrition and that there will be a
whittling down and only again you know
it's a little bit Darwinistic these
times it's survival of the fittest and I
think vote will survive and some of the
like the great fashion houses i think
the great classics will but i think some
of the peripheral players will have a
have a hard time trying to hold on
you know god I've enormous respect for
Anna she has been running vogue with an
iron fist for 20 years she is the
industry leader not only in the
publication but she is the strongest
most powerful person in that industry
I'm always amazed at her ability to turn
six months ago there was a conversation
that I might be getting too old and
losing her job and that just suddenly
morphed into a 60 minutes profile and in
this movie and so Anna goes from what's
perceived to be a you know the devil
wears prada that just you know elevated
her into the public domain an even
larger place so she's got a miraculous
way of turning all of this press
sometimes negative into a positive for
her so enormous respect for Anna what
she does what she has done to Vogue what
she continues to do for vogue you know
inshallah may she continued to hold onto
that and to do it as well as she does um
it's clearly formula that works she's an
iron point of view she's very decisive i
think her editors respect that she
doesn't waver she's got a very clear
vision on what an American woman wants
and what vogue should be that's great
I'm a different kind of a fashion editor
I look at fashion not that I don't take
it any less seriously but it gives me
great pleasure to buy a beautiful dress
to see a beautiful collection I get very
excited in that very personal way that
fashion can move you I love clothes I'm
I was the girl in school that loved
clothes I bought too many clothes i
still love clothes i like the pleasure
that clothes bring i like to see them on
the page i love to photograph them i
love to buy them for myself so to me I
certainly don't to compare myself to
adil but we're very different animals I
looked for the pleasure in fashion and
how to have a good time doing that I
have the best day job on the planet I
mean I get to look at beautiful things
look at beautiful girls talk to
designers about creativity pick things
that are just happened to think or
fantastic i mean got it
enormous luxury to be able to be
surrounded by craftsmen who are involved
in beauty and what's beautiful and and
to get that vicarious thrill of seeing
something and and and wearing it or
shooting it and putting it on so I I'd
like to be able to always hold on to the
enormous fun that fashion provides its
intelligent the designers are very smart
these are big businesses this is a huge
industry it is totally not fluff anymore
anyone's perception of that so for sure
and there are many many smart people
that are in this industry but I do think
that one of its great lasting things is
the great pleasure that it does given
all the levels that I've described and
that's why I still love it